these red bottoms these is bloody shoes
yeah I butcher that you've probably
heard cardi B's hit song Bo doc yellow
and like basically everyone else I
couldn't get enough of it that is until
cardi B released the music video did you
all see that why is she wearing a job
with a veil over her face in the middle
of the desert
MODOK yellow shows how music television
and film still paint Arabs and Muslims
and highly exotic eyes light and it's
just one example of how Orientalism is
pretty much everywhere in our pop
culture think of Aladdin think of
homeland or Sacha Baron Cohen's entire
career I made that up
hi guys I'm Omar and this Sunday on each
of us we're breaking down the concept of
Orientalism where it comes from
and why it's a problem and just know I'm
definitely going to ruin some of your
childhood favorites
I can show you though and now I'm about
to drop a whole new world of knowledge
on you Aladdin was one of the most
orientalist films of all time and
professor Walter Denny who's taught
Orientalist art for decades agrees like
those first three or four minutes of the
Disney movie Aladdin are basically very
prejudicial they create a very very
false and very very prejudicial view of
the Islamic world before I upset you
anymore let me tell you why it's so bad
by explaining what Orientalism is
historically Orientalism refers to the
study of the Arab and Muslim world or
what was for a long time referred to as
the Orient which included more than just
Arab or predominant Muslim societies and
the discipline basically looked at those
societies as though they were
interchangeable inferior and well
mystical and savage just the fact we say
there's an Arab or Muslim world is proof
of how pervasive that way of thinking
was and is but now we'll Yeomans a
professor of Media Studies and public
affairs says the definition has evolved
it's become to mean something else
a critique actually of a particular way
of knowing about that part of the world
the late Palestinian American professor
author and activist Edward Saeed wrote
the book on Orientalism making his
Palestinian Arab identity central to his
work fanaticism violence etc always
associated with the Arabs with Islam so
on and so forth Arabs are always being
killed they're always associated
publicly in the public mind and public
image with what is negative and and
regressive he called his book
Orientalism and it forever changed the
way we think of Western depictions of
the Arab and Muslim world site also said
Orientalism relies on letting Westerners
interact with the Orient without ever
losing the upper hand basically it's
about power and his criticism was that
the study of it the scholarship about
the Middle East the Near East in South
Asia was really based on a lens of
Empire so I'd also said Orientalism
presented imagery of a mysterious land
full of secrets monsters and sensual
women but the depictions weren't just
about exotic
orientalist art and literature often
served a more sinister purpose one of
the most important ideas behind
Orientalist art has been to show the
Islamic world in a position of either
moral or cultural inferiority to that of
the West and according to Saeed that
desires to show our herbs and Muslims as
morally less than had a very real impact
on the everyday lives of people living
in the so-called Orient regardless of
their ethnicity or religion it doesn't
just affect Arabs and Muslims it can
also affect black Africans Indians and
other Asians sides work dissected while
media characterizations of Arabs and
Muslims in Western news outlets look
like during and after iran's 1979
Islamic Revolution it is from the
mosques that opposition to the Shah is
being led by puritanical Shiite Muslims
the religious zealots want to return to
the constitution of 1906 the concept of
Orientalism isn't just that there are
issues with this painting or that novel
it's that this painting or that novel
both create and perpetuate inaccurate
portrayals of Muslims and Arabs it
dehumanizes anyone who falls into those
groups and supports dangerous policies
and these stereotypes bring me back to
Aladdin the late Arab American academic
Jack Shaheen identified the Orientalist
themes and tropes in a lab after its
1992 debut Shaheen campaign to make
Disney alter the opening song Arabian
Nights and you probably don't remember
this line with a console you
they don't like your face it's about
matic
seriously he just referred to a made-up
arab land as barbaric and put it to a
children's be Shaheen responded in the
LA Times and he said it was a painful
reminder to three million Americans of
Arab heritage as well as three hundred
million Arabs and others that the
abhorrent Arab stereotype is as
ubiquitous as Aladdin's lamp you might
not be able to say that it's racist but
you can say it's a misrepresentation of
cultures it's a blending of cultures all
to serve the purpose of sort of this
mainstream American entertainment Shane
also said these pictures would impact an
audience's understanding of the Arab
world and have a real world impact with
the negative portrayal of Agrabah
serving as what he called Hollywood's
fabricated Arab Lee well he may be right
in 2015 as the u.s. bombed Isis in Iraq
and Syria a poll found that 30 percent
of Republican voters would support
bombing agrabuff and before you agree a
Garba is the fictional country in
Aladdin it's not real other activist
groups criticized the film's character
portrayal with aladdin and Jasmine
having anglicized features in American
accents you're not free to make your own
choices sometimes you feel so you're
just trapped and the rest have really
fake Arabic accents and far less
attractive physical features
I had to slit a few throats but I got it
but Aladdin is not the only film in
recent memory to use Orientalist imagery
there's also Prince of Persia gods of
Egypt 300 eunuch zero dark thirty and
American sniper but that didn't stop
some of those from winning Academy
Awards you might say Aladdin is old news
why bring it up at all well it's coming
back as a live-action feature and it
doesn't seem like much has changed at
all the movie has already been accused
of whitewashing the story with the
creation of white characters like Prince
Anders if you're gonna spend a lot of
money on it you can't really do anything
real it has to be imaginative it has to
play the fantasy therefore has to rely
on stereotypes orientalist imagery has
also managed to creep on to the small
screen television shows like homeland
and 24 are among the biggest culprits
with Arabs and
often portrayed as terrorists or violent
individuals hell-bent on destroying the
United States and/or Western
civilization homeland in particular
framed Muslims as people you could never
trust under any circumstances even if
they were your neighbor but the
terrorist trope is an old one the most
sustaining sort of oriental is
stereotype is that of the terrorists you
can see that have heavily present in
1970s 1980s both literature and in film
and today we see that that is become
still a dominant role the brave is NBC's
latest military drama where good versus
evil clash and the evil happens to be
Muslims but there also happens to be one
good Muslim working with the good guys
in many ways you could say that
Hollywood mainstream movies have become
a lot more self-aware about this kind of
thing and so they try to change it up or
add a little more complexity for example
by adding in a Muslim good character as
a way to sort of balance out of Muslim
villain and then there are music videos
where Orientals images have been
pervasive for a long time but it's not
as discussed as it is in other art forms
which brings us back to boudic yellows
music video where cardi B shows up in
Dubai so mysterious so rich dresses up
an Arab garb so sensual so exotic has a
pet cheetah which is dangerous rides a
camel up across the desert a K every era
of his backyard apparently okay so maybe
car D is never even read Edwards site
and may not even know what we're talking
about but in her defense she's not the
only one doing it there are plenty of
other examples and musicians using
Orientals images in today's music videos
I see it as a form of sort of silencing
it's a form of erasure of a culture it's
oversimplification and people have a
right to be insulted by that and they
have a right to protest and demand that
they be treated with a little more
respect so what will it take to ensure
that we stop exotic izing Arabs and
Muslims and our movies TV shows and
favorite music videos love you cardi B
growing up whenever I watched a Latin I
was somehow able to separate between
that portrayal of Arabs and my own Arab
family have you guys seen this sort of
exotic eyes imagery for other
communities or in TV shows cartoons
films let us know let us also know what
you think and come back next Sunday for
another great video and don't forget to
Like share and subscribe